Speaker 1: Let's go next to SD from
Dallas, Texas SD. You're on the air.
Speaker 4: Hi, David, thanks for taking my call
again. Pleasure. So about a couple of months ago,
I forget exactly when it was I called in basically
talking about how horrible the gerrymandering was
going to be, that all of these red states were
going to break up the cities and whatnot. And
to my surprise, it actually hasn't been
going as poorly as I have suspected. And like
many have looked at this like I think, including
on I forget his name of the guy from The
Washington Post, he said it was basically a wash
at this point. So my question is that one said,
would you would you consider like, you
know, dumber ism taking for granted that
the Democrats are going to lose the House
and the Senate or concern trolling? Would you
consider that a soft form of voter suppression?
Speaker 1: You're let me see if I understand
you're saying to go around saying Democrats are
going to lose. It's a form of suppressing the
vote because if you convince Democrats they're
going to lose, they won't even bother voting.
Speaker 4: Yeah, that's part of it, yeah.
Speaker 1: Yeah, I mean, you know this,
we've looked at this on both sides. There
was a time where it was like, you know,
Trump and others saying they're going to rig
it, don't even bother. And then they would kind
of go back and forth thing. I know you should
vote and that those special Senate elections.
I think that it's unclear to me that when
people are told that they're going to lose that,
they actually don't vote. I think it's just an
empirical question and I haven't seen it studied
if people believe wrongly believe their side
is likely to lose. Are they actually less
likely to vote or do they become more likely to
vote? I don't know the answer. It's something
we could study and probably get an answer to.
Speaker 4: Yeah, like we study so much the forms
of hard voter suppression, like when it comes
to strict voter ID. And it seems like even that
it's really in determinants like whether or not
that actually has as big an affect as many of us
would say it does. Yeah. But then again, it seems
like the larger interest of the larger factors
like people's motivation to actually go out and
vote, which is why I'm kind of concerned with why
it called its soft voter suppression. Well, the
Speaker 1: other thing is, even in saying we're
going to lose, it's like you could be saying
we're going to lose, don't even bother voting,
and you could be saying we're going to lose
unless we all go out and vote. And those are
two very different things.
Speaker 4:
Yeah, I agree. Well, I'm just kind of
sensitive to like like how has said that? Well,
thank you for taking my call, David.
Speaker 1: My pleasure. My pleasure.
Good. Good topic and glad to have
the opportunity to talk about it.